[Risas]
[Música]
y un cinturón de seguridad cuando me
subo a un auto dentro de la ciudad mi
mamá me decía que no lo hacía por
resabiada
a menudo que encuentro la misma reacción
si es que no es por pereza o por
rebeldía porque alguien quisiera no
poner ese cinturón de seguridad
ya no alcancé a explicárselo a mi mamá
pero voy a intentar justificarme con
ustedes
si es que me va bien
tal vez e inclusive se me une alguien
del público más importante quizá logre
que se cuestionen toda la filosofía de
seguridad que está detrás del uso del
cinturón de seguridad
de la política pública de movilidad
al inicio yo tampoco
tenía claro por qué no me abrazaba el
cinturón o sea que si era porque sabía
lo mismo parece
tal vez empecé a entenderlo el yen que
mi hermano me prestó su volkswagen
escarabajo de los años 70 qué sorpresa
fue para mí la sensación el feeling de
manejar este auto para empezar mi vista
estaba a la misma altura que la altura
de los peatones e inclusive un poquito
más abajo por las ventoleras se acuerdan
esas ventanitas triangulares que había
no de autos que era siempre lo primero
que se rompía
ventolera se filtraba el viento y los
ruidos de la calle
para curvar había que hacer fuerza y el
volante transmitía la vibración de los
adoquines de la bajada de guapo
lo mismo con el freno casi casi que se
sentía en la planta del pie la fricción
de los metales
y como no
se oye a la hebilla del cinturón de
seguridad golpear contra la ventana como
cuando estos autos eran nuevos y nadie
los usaba
lo que más me sorprendió fue cuanto más
se parecía
esta experiencia a manejar mi bicicleta
que es mi modo habitual de movilizar me
que a manejar un auto de los de ahora
qué pasó cómo llegamos del carismático
pichirilo de hace 50 años a los tanques
de guerra que son que son nuestra
aspiración ahora
los factores involucrados son múltiples
pero aquí quisiera centrarme en la
manera en que se cambió
el pensamiento sobre la seguridad vial y
sobre todo cuando hablamos de seguridad
hablamos sobre la seguridad de kim
el automóvil causó muertos y heridos
desde que entró a las ciudades
tanto entre los peatones como entre sus
usuarios
poco a poco se fueron incorporando
elementos de seguridad que hicieron más
seguro para los conductores
la actividad de conducir
pero hasta mediados del siglo pasado
principalmente se intentaba reducir los
accidentes mediante la educación y la
sanción a los conductores a quienes se
veía como como unos locos temerarios
esto cambió en los años 60
se empezó a ver como inevitable lo que
se llamó el primer choque y se puso más
de énfasis en intentar que el segundo
choque es decir el choque de los cuerpos
de los ocupantes contra las estructuras
del carro sea lo menos dañino posible
es así que en 1966 en eeuu se volvieron
obligatorias en todos los modelos muchas
de las innovaciones que tenemos ahora en
los automóviles los parabrisas laminados
las cámaras reforzadas para los
ocupantes y los cinturones de tres
anclajes todo eso pero el momento
crucial crucial llegó en 1979
ahí se abandonó el énfasis en la
regulación y se creó el programa de
evaluación de automóviles nuevos que
estableció pruebas de choques
a estimar cuál era el efecto de esos
choques en los ocupantes
de acuerdo a los resultados de esas
pruebas se empezaron a pegar las
calificaciones
de seguridad de los autos en los
parabrisas para que sean los
consumidores informados los que escojan
el auto más seguro entre comillas quien
ha visto esas pruebas con esos de
maniquís
tan carismáticos que les estrellan
contra las paredes
seguramente casi todos y no es
casualidad es porque fueron parte de una
intensa campaña de la industria y de las
autoridades para cambiar la forma en que
el público entendía la seguridad vial
a partir de ahí la seguridad pasó a ser
parte central del mercadeo de los
vehículos y los clientes empezaron a
exigir más y más sofisticados elementos
de seguridad esta lógica de la seguridad
también hizo a los carros cada vez más
grandes
aunque aquí también intervienen otros
miedos culturales
las guerras del golfo y el ataque a las
torres gemelas por ejemplo popularizaron
en las calles los hammers y todos los
modelos parecidos que originalmente fue
fueron diseñados para combatir en el
desierto
las crisis de las masculinidades blancas
también ha fomentado un auge de estos
carros acorazados donde donde poder
refugiarse
en latinoamérica y en el ecuador las
grandes desigualdades convierten al
carro en una burbuja donde sus ocupantes
buscan aislarse del espacio público que
se percibe como peligroso y contaminante
no solo la marca sino también el tamaño
de los carros
sirve para distanciarse de populacho
para elevar la autoestima y aquí está
bien dicho porque es autoestima
así en el 2020 el 77 por ciento de los
autos vendidos en eeuu fueron o vans o
camionetas todoterrenos en ecuador igual
las las importaciones de vehículos
sobredimensionados pasaron de ser el 39
por ciento en la década de los noventas
a ser el 53 por ciento en los últimos 10
años a pesar de que cuestan el doble en
promedio que los grandes
uno de los múltiples problemas con estos
carros es que son mucho más peligrosos
para los otros actores de las calles si
es que un peatón es atropellado por un
todoterreno tiene de dos a tres veces
más probabilidades de vivir de morir que
si se queda atropellado por un auto
pequeño
está además la manera en que se percibe
el mundo adentro de estos tanques de
guerra o más bien dicho en que no se
percibe el mundo
es que este es otro de los ejes del
mercadeo de los automóviles el confort y
el confort de entendido como aislarse lo
más posible
del exterior
la suspensión más suave para no sentir
el camino los asientos elevados para
estar por encima del mundo los
interiores más silenciosos con el equipo
de sonido más potente
no solo que se percibe menos a los
peatones sino que se percibe menos la
velocidad y la velocidad es una asesina
fiable
mientras que a 30 kilómetros por hora la
probabilidad de que el atropellado muera
es menor al 10% cuando es cuando el auto
va a 50 kilómetros por hora ya sube a
más de 50% y si es que a 90 kilómetros
por hora es casi una certeza
el efecto que quiero destacar de estos
cambios en los automóviles es que los
conductores ahora tienen una mucho mayor
sensación de seguridad en los setentas
un economista llamado sam pels man
propuso que los conductores al sentirse
más seguros por el simple don de
seguridad estaban tomando más riesgos
y estaban causando más accidentes
y lo más importante para medio argumento
que las ganancias de seguridad dentro
del automóvil estaban pagando les los
que quedaban por fuera las estadísticas
actuales parecen confirmarlo
a pesar de cinturones de seguridad
inteligentes cabinas de acero reforzado
y airbags por los cuatro costados la
situación no mejora en el mundo mueren
1.35 millones de personas al año en
accidentes viales y 20 y de 20 a 50
millones más
quedan iniciados algunos de ellos
deshabilitados de por vida
en eeuu a pesar de los encierros por la
pandemia el 2020 fue el año con más
muertes en las calles
desde hace 96 años
y mientras los miras las muertes de los
conductores y de los pasajeros se han
mantenido constantes las de peatones y
ciclistas siguen subiendo
en nuestro país en ecuador desde el 2000
hasta el 2019 las muertes en las vías
más que se han duplicado la versión
cerca de 4000 al año y ahora se acercan
a las 4000 al año para niños de entre 12
y 17 años que no manejan ojo son la
primera causa de muertes para jóvenes
entre 18 y 19 años no solamente que es
la primera causa de muertes sino que
constituyen el 26 por ciento de todos
los decesos
repitámoslo un cuarto de los jóvenes que
murieron en 2019 murieron víctimas de la
violencia vial
sobre las muertes de peatones y
ciclistas ni siquiera información
constante confiable pero constituyen al
menos un tercio del total
i
un espacio público asignado por el miedo
en que los peatones no pueden salirse de
los precarios espacios que les han
asignado en que la distracción la
indisciplina o la impericia se pagan con
la vida
no es solamente problemático por los
muertos directos qué causa es insalubre
en todos los sentidos
desde lo económico hasta que hasta el
ejercicio de la ciudadanía
pongamos un ejemplo tristísimo de esto
si es que no mueren aún más niños y
viejos en las calles es porque ya no
salen no pueden salir solos los carros
los mantienen encerrados en sus casas
nos hemos acostumbrado a compartir
espacio con los carros pero quisiera
mostrarles unos vídeos para que vuelvan
a apreciar el riesgo visceral que esto
significa
fíjense que los carros nos van a una
velocidad inusual
los dos últimos vídeos son aquí en la
gonzález suárez que es una calle
residencial considerada pacífica donde
ya se han registrado algunos eventos de
estos de terror no a propósito no
incluye vídeos en que muere gente pero
la gente se muere un bólido de más de
dos toneladas y de 400 caballos de
fuerza no es coteja para un chasis de
carne y huesos
por suerte
no es inevitable porque no es irracional
llevar a cuestas
una habitación de acero de dos toneladas
cada vez que queremos movilizar
un par de quintales que es lo que pesa
su cargamento humano
la industria automotriz intenta mantener
la vigencia del automóvil a través de
soluciones tecnológicas detectores de
peatones frenos automáticos manejo
autónomo
pero podemos buscar otras soluciones más
económicas rápidas y garantizadas
reducir el abismo en la vulnerabilidad
de los diferentes actores de las calles
la carrera armamentista si autos cada
vez más grandes acorazados y seguros
para sus ocupantes logra justo lo
contrario acentúa ese abismo
para que las calles sean en verdad
espacios libres de miedo todos los
usuarios de la calle deben ser igual de
vulnerables que es lo mismo que decir
igual de que seguros igual de seguros
hay que segregar los cuerpos de los
carros no son ideas nuevas ni radicales
ni realizables lo están haciendo en
otros lados cientos de ciudades en el
mundo han adoptado lo que se llama
visión cero en sus políticas de
movilidad
es el modelo escandinavo que tiene como
un principio explícito que inclusive una
muerte en las vías es inaceptable
este si vas peatonización es de las
ciudades y de los centros de las
ciudades la marginación del automóvil
del espacio público y de el centro de
las políticas públicas están arrojando
asombrosos resultados pero no hay que ir
tan lejos para avisorar lo que podrían
ser nuestras calles aquí en la ciudad de
quito todos los domingos más de 50.000
personas atraviesan la urbe de sur a
norte
ciclistas ocasionales niños aprendiendo
a montar bicicleta personas con mascotas
paseantes distraídos adolescentes
irresponsables deportistas temerarios
casi todos sin casco todo sin movimiento
si reglas claras
durante los 18 años y que está vigente
el ciclopaseo han pasado por ahí 40
millones de personas o más
durante todo ese tiempo se ha registrado
una sola muerte cuál es el truco
milagroso que no pueden entrar los autos
donde se considera inevitable que entre
el auto hay que transformarlo hay que
ciudadanizar lo desarmarlo apaciguarlo
lo primero podría ser quitar el cinturón
de seguridad porque no necesita ir tan
rápido
necesita ocupar menos espacio y dejar de
emitir vapores tóxicos
tiene que ser más eficiente más ágil
menos aparatoso
para mejorar su conexión con el exterior
se le puede eliminar las ventanas y los
parabrisas
por fortuna y hay un prototipo avanzado
de este carro inteligente a partir de
ahí podemos seguir imaginando y
construyendo lo que queramos
[Aplausos]